Thank you.
Okay.
I'm going to open the hearing on Senate Bill 227 and recess until 1130.
Thank you.
I'm going to go off the record and I'm going to say I appreciate you guys getting me out of my work upstairs.
Well, we'll come out of recess for Senate Bill 227.
We're going to wait a couple of minutes because we were just in full finance, and we've got to wait for the rest of the committee to show up.
So I'm in the finest military fashion.
We'll hurry up and wait.
I think we're live streaming, so I don't see anything off color.
As we've been reminded, all mics are hot.
Right.
GeoLine's had a field day in the last two years.
It was recorded sessions between the auto-captioning.
Oh, right.
Holy cow, right?
I still call Pataparami the Pataparami.
Because that was just, it's like, you know, but a computer does it.
You're kind of at the mercy of this, you know, intelligent software.
And the pronunciation, right.
It's not going to adapt to the New Hampshire accent.
No.
I didn't bring my name tag.
Nobody did.
And I think Division I will be actually in Division II room this afternoon at 2 o'clock for 409 because we were asked to take that over.
What are we doing this afternoon?
At 2 o'clock in the Division II room, we will be having a work session for 409.
Is that a joint work session?
No, no.
She just asked if it was more in Division our lane rather than theirs.
Okay, so for 227, I have asked Mike Hoffman to see if the language can be amended as was suggested during full finance to include the probation, parole, corrections line personnel.
is there anything else that we want to do because what I'm going to do is if anybody has any anything else to add I'll be glad to hear it.
But my intention is to recess this.
If that's all the language you're going to change or if we want to change something else, then we can reconvene at 2 o'clock just to vote the amendment.
So, Representative.
As was mentioned, volunteers, EMT and fire volunteers, maybe if there could be some sort of explicit language, if people agree with that, that would definitely include them and take any ambiguity out of it.
I don't know if that's needed or not, but that's my thoughts.
I've been involved in a case with the Department of Labor Thank you.
include them and take any ambiguity out of it I don't know if that's needed or not but that's I've been I've been involved in a case with the Department of Labor in the past as a witness not not as a plaintiff I wasn't in trouble what am I trying the Department of Labor doesn't consider compensation part of employment.
If you say you're working for this town of Hampton as a volunteer firefighter, you're an employee.
If the town Hampton recognizes you as an employee, they don't have to pay anything.
So the actual compensation is not required.
So the compensatory remuneration is not part of the whole?
Not part of employment.
Thanks.
Yeah, Representative Griffin.
I'm looking at line five, the end of line five, where they made a change with their amendment, I guess, is to say death by suicide shall be considered a work related cause of death right to me that that's it the person dies of suicide it's work related that isn't what I heard in the testimony in the other room well I heard that there was an investigation, and there's a determination made as part of that investigation.
Is that, that's how the process works?
No, come on up.
These are streamed.
So thank you, Representative Steve Pearson, Ruckingham District 6 Dairy.
I sit on the PTSD commission along with a couple of my colleagues behind me.
What happens is there's a single entity in the state of New Hampshire where this all goes to.
We actually addressed this in a meeting just three days ago.
I asked that question as to, you know, do I have different agencies that look at this to determine this?
It goes to the labor board, one group.
They focus on all of it.
So that procedure has to happen as far as determination, and they go through the whole process.
This is not just snap the finger and we've skipped all the normal things.
That's not how this's this works at all so that is very much part of the the process the other thing from a policy side since I'm in the hot seat when ED&A heard this when when we talked with the world the Corrections folks that was encompassing when we talked about Corrections officers they're asking for a clarification then it just has to do with specific references in 100 a that that does not change what we saw in policy at all.
That's how we processed it, if you will, as being all of the folks in that world.
So there's no policy differentiation by just making a clarification, because that was the intent when it went through us.
So just so you know.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Leishman.
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
We had a House bill that we passed on here.
Correct.
Which is very similar.
How similar to this?
So House Bill 91, Representative Abbess' bill, is similar but not...
I don't have it in front of me.
It's the substantive action is the same.
This is just a little bit more specific than what 91, here we go, thank you, the 91 was.
This is, oh, this is the full shebango.
So 91, which I believe, are you asking, Representative, because of your amendments that were brought on to 91?
Because I see your, let yeah so so the amendment that's being asked for here in finance puts it more in line with what you did with your amendment in House Bill 91 specifically so the Corrections line personnel is the...
looks like the bulk of the difference.
So this would just put that back in line with...
So Representative Mooney was kind enough to show me some technology and I see the Senate interim studied 91.
Yes, the Senate has put their full faith and weight, my understanding, with 227.
Thanks.
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
Okay, just for the, yes, Representative Walz.
I'm sorry for being late, but as I was walking in and out, I think I heard Representative Irv saying, if I'm not right, that death by suicide shall be considered a work-related cause of death.
Is that what you were asking about?
Yes, that's if I'm not right, that death by suicide shall be considered a work-related cause of death.
Yes, that's what I'm asking about because the way I read that, no matter what the process is, those boards are going to have to go back to this law and the law says death by suicide shall be considered.
Right, considered.
It's not a presumption bill because considered I'm going to be as a lawyer I read this, and it doesn't say shall be looked at as a possible.
Shall be considered a cause of death is the same as shall be presumed.
And in this current wording, I believe that it basically says it shall be presumed as a cause of death.
If we wanted to say considered a factor, I think we would need to amend it or considered it's a possible cause of death, we would need to amend it.
But honestly, I read this language as basically saying, like Representative Irv did, this is a presumption.
The PTSD Commission, I will tell you, is pretty adamant that the watering down of that will make this bill useless.
It's going to need to have some teeth as far as as far as how's that's worded.
And, you know, I appreciate your interpretation of the word considered, but I this there's other presumption bills that I've been involved with in my time here that have used much stronger language than the word considered.
And again, the procedural part of this, it must go before the board.
There is an investigative process involved in this.
And that doesn't change.
This does not eliminate that procedural part of the investigation.
But what you've done is taken the discretion away from the board.
By using this language and effectively creating creating a presumption It may need to go before the board, but the board no longer has description to find otherwise We are forcing the board to recognize that this that suicide Is a absolute factor or the work part of folks in these services is An absolute factor in suicide that is what that is what this bill does it it forces them to acknowledge that and go through the process of that which currently they don't have to do so from my point of view I'm fine with this I'm fine if it said presumption I think when you've got a suicide there it's you know anybody who is a first responder in any form has psychological implications of that.
I don't care what form you're doing it in, you are affected by it.
I have no problem with this.
I just wanna make sure we as a committee understand what we're doing.
And the lawyer in me says that this is the same, maybe Representative would disagree, but the lawyer in me says this is creating a presumption, and which I'm fine with.
In all honesty, I'm fine with it.
I think we should be giving death benefits no matter what.
But we need to understand what we're doing.
How many things do we not all the lawyers?
But if I may, Mr.
Chair, as Representative Walts is saying, my memory of my Funk and Wangle, my favorite dictionary, considered as past tense.
It's an adjective.
It's something that has been done completed.
It's not a direction to do something.
It's something that's been done.
So as Representative Wall say, end of story.
It shall be considered part of the suicide.
So that's great.
That's the way it should be.
Unfortunately, we can't, this sounds gauche, but it's just true.
You can't ask a suicide person what were the causes.
It's just anecdotal, but that's what we got.
You have something, please come up to the...
You've got to have a mic.
These days we're live streaming.
Everybody has to talk in a mic in listening Holly Stevens for the record I am the public policy director of NAMI New Hampshire and in listening to you speak I'm also an attorney and I think the what they're saying is just like if an officer has an accident in their cruiser, that that is considered a line of duty death.
However, they're still going to do an investigation to see whether that was the proximate cause, because if they find out that maybe the officer was you know off-duty in their cruiser under the influence the Department of Labor could come back and say well you know that doesn't count or maybe they're on duty but you know so that the is still done.
This is just saying that just like being shot while you're on duty shall be considered a work-related death.
That suicide is just another one on those lists, on that list.
But I think the Department of Labor would still do their due diligence just as they would for any other death in the line of duty.
Does that make sense?
It's just not what the language says.
I understand the procedure, but that's not what this language says.
My job is to look at the language before us, and the language before us says to me it basically creates a presumption.
So I would just argue if we're trying to do that, if that's what we're trying to do, then we need to have different language.
That's all I'm trying to say.
I, as I said all along, if we created the presumption, I would be fine with it.
I'm happy to give these line of duty deaths, but we also need to look at the language before us.
And to me, the language before us reads as a presumption.
And I understand that the wording is ambiguous at best, but I was just looking back to the previous line, which talks about that they still have to look at whether the injuries are a direct or proximate cause of the death.
So I think that that's where the investigation comes in, but that's just my reading of it.
I will have to bounce the ball back to Representative Walz and say, if you want to change the language, this is your idea.
You've got to come up with the language.
I don't have a problem with it as it's written.
But if you want to change it, let me know.
Let us know.
I don't want to change it.
I just want to make sure the committee understands what they're doing.
I am comfortable with this language, but my reading of it conflicts with the testimony, and I wanted to make sure the committee's doing it eyes wide open.
Okay.
By all means, I mean.
So the, thank you, thank you, Chairman.
The Department of Labor has a seat on the PTSD commission and was present for the meeting that we had not more than three days ago where we discussed in length the procedure of this.
They didn't raise any concerns about this doing what you're telling me you think it's going to do.
So they are still fully going through the process of the investigations, the procedures, looking at the causation and all of that.
So I mean, if the Department of Labor had made an an objection to this, by all means, I would certainly be telling you as a matter of the Commission's findings, but it's just not there, so.
Okay, thank you.
Just so you'll know my intentions, I've asked Mr.
Hoffman to modify the language as recommended by corrections to include the additional functions that they outlined.
I did not include the juvenile side of it because I'm not that familiar with it and I don't know that we wanna be planting our big foot in their business not knowing how their processes are.
I just, now we're taking something that has to do with group two and applying it to a different group over here that is not group two.
It's my understanding, so if you want to do that in subsequent legislation, by all means, but I think at this time we really have to look at this as a Group 2 issue and not other departments or functions.
Can we find out if JPPOs are Group 2?
Because I think they may be.
They're not.
They're not?
We know that?
Okay.
Thanks.
So with that said, we'll have an amendment by 2 o'clock, and Division I is in the Division II room at 2 o'clock, because we are going to have the work session on 409, not Division but it's posted to be in that yep yeah yeah go ahead Mike I believe that division two is working on 409 as we speak only because I got a request from one of the members of Division 2 for amendment and then I just touch base with Mickey well chairman said she wanted us to hear it but if we don't have to hear it that's good okay but so we'll reconvene still when do you think we can have the amendment I asked for it rush and at that time I thought we'd be Reconvening at 1 so hopefully we should be all set for 2 o'clock.
Well, we'll have yeah full finances Reconvening at 1 and 1 30 for hearings.
So we'll recess this until 2 o'clock And consider the amendment to move this out of the work session and I apologize for 409 I The chairman the chair woman asked me to us to take it over but she changed her mind.
So All right, so we are recessed until 2 o'clock Thank you.
I still think that the language of the bill lies in the face of the testimony.
I mean, I don't care about the language of the bill.
I read it initially.
Well, I think it lies in the face of the testimony.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay, so I'll open the work session on Senate Bill 371 and recess it until we are done with a vote on Senate bill 227 as soon as the balance of the committee shows up we'll have a vote It is on?
Okay.
We'll just sit quietly and anybody out in the audience will think the sound's not working.
Well, I guess technically we could hold a vote now.
I know.
I'm just joking.
I'm confused I know.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
We're taking a vote on 371?
No, we're taking a vote on 227.
Yeah, but I mean...
Oh, we'll vote on 371 eventually, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, there we go.
How was your coffee break?
They went to the post- Okay.
Mr.
Hoppin, you want to just see what happened with the amendment here?
When you look at this amendment number 1338 you'll see section 2 is the paragraph that was in 227 Senate bill 227 that came into the committee and the drafting attorneys clarified this by instead of adding corrections officers in Section 2, they actually included it as part of the definition of police officer.
And if this looks familiar, it is because it was also in House Bill 1319, which passed the House.
So we had House Bill 91 that passed the House and House Bill 1319.
I kept saying 91 earlier.
So this is consistent with the House position and it's drafted a little bit differently than what you saw this morning.
But it includes everybody we talked about.
It includes all the corrections officers, probation and parole officers, and correctional line personnel in Group 2.
Okay.
You got to turn your mic on, please.
Is that another way of saying it includes everybody in group two?
I think so.
But it also includes some people who are in group one.
Who's in group one?
Anybody that works in the correctional line personnel could conceivably in group one and not in group two a psychologist a uh yeah i knew somebody working as a psychologist at the prison i guess for some reason thought they were group two too but i guess they're not okay administrative people would be also group two okay i actually think because of the way number four is written meeting the definition of permanent policeman that it would be those individuals who have attended the academy and are in group two okay so maybe not necessarily the psychologist or the uh medical staff okay when we get to when we start slicing the cheese this thin yeah exactly it gets a little shaky okay i'll go on with that question yes certainly so this morning I thought the testimony was just to include all line personnel, not those limited to group two.
Am I wrong?
I see Jay Ward shaking his head in the back.
Am I wrong, Jay?
Yeah.
Okay.
So it's only the people that were put into group two, and that was done about three or four years ago.
There was about 35 positions leaving that went over.
And so there are blind staff that are not in the police.
Okay.
Thank you.
You don't need the definition.
Thank you for correcting my faulty memory.
Okay.
Representative Griffin.
So, Mr.
Chairman, for the purposes of moving forward, I would like to move amendment 1330H.
Okay.
Do we have a second?
Second by Representative Leishman.
If the clerk's ready, we could call the roll.
Second by.
This is to approve the amendment, not the bill.
Okay.
And the motion is to...
Adopt amendment 1330.
Okay.
All right.
The chairman votes.
Yes.
The vice chairman votes.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Mooney.
Yes.
Representative Leishman.
Representative Hatch is absent.
Representative Walz.
Yes.
Motion passes six to nothing Mr.
Chairman.
Okay, I entertain a motion for the bill as amended.
So moved.
I'll second by Representative Walz, motion by Representative Griffin.
So this is 227A.
Okay, you wanna call the roll?
Yes, we'll call it.
All right.
Okay, the motion is OTA on House Bill 227.
Senate Bill.
Senate Bill 227.
The amendment number is 2022-111330H.
If you're in favor, you vote affirmative, now you're voting negative.
I'm out of practice.
Okay, the chairman votes.
Yes.
Okay.
So I'm close the hearing on 227 and reopen the hearing on Senate bill.
Senate bill.
Yes.
Okay.
So I'm close the hearing on 227 and reopen the hearing on Senate bill.
so I to close the hearing on 227 and reopen the hearing on Senate Bill 371.
Okay, we heard testimony in full finance.
Does anybody here want to add anything or make any additional comments?
You're welcome to say, if you like, please.
we want to make sure we get it right thank you mr chairman Ben Frost from New Hampshire housing after the hearing in full finance I had a sidebar discussion with Adam Schmidt who is representative for the New Hampshire Association of Realtors, and he reminded me of the compromise nature of the legislation that created the lead fund in the 2019 biennial budget trailer bill.
And part of that compromise was concessions by property owner representatives yielding to the changed testing regime for lead paint poisoning in exchange for funding to do the work that's necessary or made in part necessary because of the increased incidences of properties going under order from the Department of Health and Human Services.
So additional funding is consistent with that compromise and would be welcome.
Okay.
I spent several years in real estate and had many hours of instruction about lead paint.
So I'm very familiar with the topic.
Great.
Any questions?
Say again?
You know more than me.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Leishman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
So, Mr.
Frost, I just had a quick question for you you since you seem to be very knowledgeable in this how many units are still out there do we know that have lead paint problems we just like touching the tip of the iceberg are we getting into the iceberg we are I don't have an accurate count for you.
We have something on the order of 500,000 residential units in the state.
I could give you an estimate of the pre-78 based on the 1980 census, which would give you a pretty close estimate of the number of pre-78 structures or pre-78 housing units, which includes all units in a large residential apartment building.
We're talking about many.
I'm going to give a scale number here.
100,000, 200,000, and we're doing hundreds of units at a time.
So we are just touching the tip of the iceberg.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Well, some of this remediation could have been executed by landlords because for a long period of time it was the landlord's responsibility to bring them up to speed so so and ultimately sir it is still the landlord's responsibility right except they get a little help from their friends right anyone else like to make a comment about senate bill 371.
Yeah.
Mr.
Chairman, I move that we approve Senate Bill 371.
Okay.
Do I have a second?
Second by Representative Leishman.
When the clerk's ready, we can call the roll.
And if you're in favor, you'll say yes.
And if you're not, you say no.
No.
How'd I do?
Really good.
All right.
For the roll call, the chairman votes.
Yes.
The vice chairman?
The clerk votes yes.
Thank you.
Really good.
All right.
For the roll call, the chairman votes.
Yes.
The vice chairman.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Mooney.
Yes.
Representative Leishman.
Representative Hatch.
Yes.
Representative Fultz.
Mr.
Chairman, the vote is seven to nothing and passes.
Okay.
Well, I think that concludes our business.
I don't know when we'll meet next because we don't know how many more bills we're gonna get but thank you for your efforts and we won't see you this week maybe next week we're adjourned I know that's that's where it was posted.
We tried not getting your vote bill.
Right now, I don't think we'll be meeting because we don't have any additional bills.
Thank you.